business people or technology people are
basically
betting their career on this technology
solution because if it works well
they're the hero
if it doesn't work well you know it can
be damaging to their career
[Music]
russell rothstein thank you so much for
being on my show how are you
very good michael glad you're good to
have you you're calling all the way from
odin right
i am i am so uh we're in our israel
office
halfway between jerusalem and tel aviv
why modern
why you know i know tel aviv i know it's
aliyah why why modin
uh well modin is actually one of
israel's fastest growing
metropolitan areas uh it's it's
also uh for those of you who are
interested in history
the place where the maccabees um started
thousands of years ago so it's a great
place it's very inspiring it's a place
where
this small group of uh soldiers
um fought against a much larger enemy so
it's very
well suited for building a startup of
course
of course and actually you know i came
to visit you you in the offices
about a year and a half ago and and it's
a wonderful beautiful area
and and definitely a place that i need
to come more often to
but but russell i want you to before we
talk about it central and talk about
covert 19 and what it's like to manage a
team
during this crisis i want to go back a
little bit about your journey
from harvard mit mit sloan talk to me a
into the business world and intro
entrepreneurship
what was that trigger for you that got
you thinking okay i want to be part of
this tech ecosystem
yeah sure um well i'd say it even starts
before college
i'm from the bronx born and bred
and i didn't necessarily going into
college
i didn't uh i didn't know that i was
going to study computer science
that's what i did my bachelor's in
computer science
i didn't know that at the time going
into it
really only until sophomore year did i
really hone in on computer science and
found i enjoyed the courses there
and so just followed that went with that
journey and then
um worked in a technical capacity i
worked at oracle
as my first job at a college
uh deploying oracle databases and oracle
applications
did a lot of sql work but
i at the time i really started to
think about what my passion was
what my strengths were i really enjoyed
that interaction
of solving problems for for customers
meaning deploying databases deploying
that application you know that point
we're actually
getting something that's valuable to
them i liked interacting with the
customers i didn't want to just be
sitting in front of
the computer all day i really enjoyed
talking to the people and understanding
them and not just socially but also
professionally
what they're doing what's what's this
database all about what's this
application all about
and then started to think about from my
career and it
led to me to go to more of a
business less technical route
i went to mit i started at mit
or began my mit journey uh in a master's
program studying technology and policy
setting
telecommunications policy and then i
decided to
take an additional year at mit a third
year
and got an mba from sloan um so i did
masters in mba and
and really so since then i moved into
the business marketing side of
technology after i graduated business
school
very very cool okay so now and now we're
talking about it central so you're in
modern and you're running and you're
running this very cool startup
talk to me a little bit about b2b
reviews
and understanding software what what
is it central and what problem are you
trying to solve because i think it's a
problem that especially
you know young entrepreneurs we we don't
really get exposed yet
to this area we're much more i think but
we much get exposed to we get exposed
much more to b2c
uh talk to me a little bit about that
exactly um
so it really began like you said it
began
with my expertise and knowledge of the
b2b
space and and even within b2b the
enterprise
technology space so i worked in my
career
in enterprise technology enterprise
software companies i mentioned
oracle i worked at companies that
developed software to manage performance
of applications
manage networks um
the kind of software solutions that
larger businesses would use it banks
insurance companies large retailers
and so that's the world that i began to
to really
know well and so on one hand i was
developing this
knowledge and and uh really uh
intellectual curiosity and love of the
enterprise tech
base but in addition
i was always really intrigued by social
media and a lot of the new
trends going on in b2c i was a very
early user of twitter um
going back long-term history i mean i i
was
i i created my own website again very
in the late 90s wow and
so i've always been interested in the
conversion of the two
and so so the story behind it central
station really began
in 2011 and i was having dinner
with a friend of mine uh naftali marcus
and um he's now the co-founder of the
company but at the time we were just
talking about
ideas right and he also
when you talk about ideas so you had an
intention to start a company together
and you were rolling off
ideas off of each other or how did that
work yeah
you know listen i um you know there's
there's different types of entrepreneurs
out there there's there's those
entrepreneurs that
you know every day you you talk to them
you meet with them and like
every hour they're coming out with
really interesting ideas they're they're
always um
they're just overflowing with ideas for
companies or startups
i'm not that kind of person okay my my
ideas for startup come once every 10
years
okay so um
but but i had this idea again about
uh in in 2011
and um i invited uh naftali who
uh i had a lot of respect for i have a
lot of respect for and
um had some you know ideas
to get him involved um and so i i really
i explained to him that
so we have we're having dinner it was in
manhattan
uh we're having uh some homeless and
kebabs
course exactly uh and
um i again this was this this was
a time where there weren't such things
as b2b review sites
and so so again before we go into into
the actual part what is the problem
speech that you're trying to solve so
there aren't b2b review sites what does
that even mean you know as a young
consumer i don't even know what
why why we need to be review sites
exactly so so and
and that's what i explained to naphtali
over this dinner i said
here i was and i just traveled to new
york i stayed at a hotel
and and i used reviews from trip advisor
to help me make a decision about which
hotel would yeah it's really important i
mean
i think it's it's sort of obvious that
before you make any important purchase
today you want to go online and read
reviews whether those are
amazon reviews yelp reviews what have
you
um but um am i in the business world
right in where i was working with
enterprise technology professionals
so these these people these it managers
cios
enterprise technology folks their
responsibility was to
choose software or choose technology for
their business
a new cyber security solution to help
their business stay more secure
some type of new software to help them
build applications
better faster a new type of a new type
of application to manage their business
and they did not have access to
reviews they did not have access to easy
way
to tap into the knowledge of other
people
who had already checked the market who'd
rather already research solutions ready
to use some of those solutions
what my intuition is what my intuition
is guiding me is saying you know when i
look and to buy
headphones there may be 500 different
types of headphones at all sorts of
price variations and it's really really
it's a really congested market when i
think of a cyber
security solution for my company maybe
there's like
three four good solutions not 500 maybe
i'm wrong but my intuition just says
that maybe
because there's less reviews it's a
little easier or less product it's a
little easier but maybe i'm wrong
um well it depends you know enterprise
tech is
it's a huge market it's three trillion
dollars
trillion dollars is spent every year on
enterprise technology solutions
so there are some markets where there
are you know take it service management
and many
in many cyber security there are dozens
of solutions out there it's
very it's very confusing and and
different than headphones
very different than headphones because
headphones you it's sort of the
same use case right you're using it to
listen to your music
and maybe they've got some different
features
um the these different types of
enterprise technology solutions
are are more complex and so it's
oftentimes it's comparing apples with
oranges or
one type of apple with a different type
of apple and so
it's a very very complex so even if
there are just a handful and oftentimes
there are dozens but even without just a
handful
it's it's a very it can be a very
complicated buying process and so it's
really helpful to talk to people already
gone
through that and then gone through the
market so it
so it again going back to that dinner
i i i said it how could it be that
that i had all access to all these
reviews
when i was just choosing a hotel which
you know not the not the most crucial
decision in the world for me but
but business people or technology people
are basically
betting their career on this technology
solution because if it works well
they're the hero
if it doesn't work well you know it can
be damaging to their career
um and obviously it can save the company
millions of dollars
to make the right technology purchase
where you obviously you can lose lots of
money if it's if it's the wrong purchase
so so important so strategic and so so
that
that's how we got to starting it central
station it it's the leading review site
real authentic reviews written by
enterprise technology professionals so
it's not b2c
and even within b2b it's not targeted
for the small medium business market
it's targeted to enterprise technology
buyers with their unique needs
how do you get people to write the
reviews so how do you get this the cio
or or the vp rnd to come in and then say
yes i've purchased this cyber security
software we've been using it for three
months and we're happy or unhappy and
here's why
yeah um yeah so it's really important
because
um it's it's not a question of just um
you don't want just to have a really
short review right i mean
that's not you know that could be
helpful you know i'm that might be good
for me when i'm choosing a hotel
you know i just want to know you know a
lot of people say that the you want
to know how many stars out of five you
don't necessarily
care about the little details exactly
exactly so but
so for but for enterprise technology
buyers it's much more important to have
that in-depth
content because someone evaluating
technology enterprise technology for
their business they have a whole lot of
questions that they want to ask they
want to know right
again it's what is what is the use case
that they're using it for
um how is the implementation uh what's
the business case
what's the return on investment uh
where's the room for improvement
what other pieces of advice what's the
best
licensing strategy to work with this
vendor
right there's a lot of information there
so
our strategy has been not only to get
reviews
but focus on the quality of the reviews
so it's it's not a numbers game it's not
get
getting you know millions and millions
of reviews it's getting that reviews
that are generally valuable to help
people make buying decisions in their
enterprise technology purpose and so
the kind of incentives that we put in
place is very different than the kind of
incentives
that you might see in b2c review sites
so b2c review sites
you know there's a lot of you know first
of all there's sometimes issues with
fake reviews
people giving up gift cards yeah and all
those things to incentivize people and
it sometimes creates bad actors
um we've decided to do zero zero
financial incentives we don't pay people
to write reviews and that's really
important
really really important not to pay
people pay people to to provide reviews
and really it's observing um if you're
familiar with the the maslow hierarchy
of course right so so uh of needs
so the the bottom here at the bottom are
more of those sort of physical needs and
and so so to motivate people by giving
them either
financial incentives you know write a
review we'll give you a a ten dollar
gift card or a five dollar starbucks
card
that's that's at the low part of the
maslow hierarchy
right the upper part of the maslow
hierarchy is is self
actualization that's the type of the
mental hierarchy
and and that's and we so those are the
levers that we pull
right so we provide ways for our
reviewers to see how
providing review um helps helps the
community
right the altruism is a very strong
strong force for many people
two is it's a way for you to be seen as
a thought leader especially in today's
market especially today's market if
you're a technology person how do you
promote yourself how do you get your
net your promotion how do you get your
next your next job
it's by showing that you're
knowledgeable about a particular
solution right if you're really an
expert
at this you know salesforce
implementation
at the cyber security deployment
whatever it is
then um you're going to be more valuable
out there in the market and so
so we're able to use these
levers to get people to provide more
in-depth
in-depth reviews how we find these
people so there's really two ways that
we
find people who are providing reviews
one is members of our community
we have four hundred thousand registered
members in i.t central state
wow and so they're actively providing
reviews we do solicit reviews from them
um they're answering questions because
because we've focused on that
community aspect of it they stay engaged
with the platform
wow one one is our process to continue
to solicit reviews from our community
um and the second aspect is um
there are lots of technology companies
that simply want more reviews of their
products
um and that's part of our business model
we're fully transparent about it it's
called reviews as a service
and so the way that'll work is that
if a company wants more reviews of its
products
it will run our reviews as a script
reuse as a service subscription program
with it central station um they will
provide us
with lists of their customers and then
we
as an independent third party very cool
completely neutral
collect those reviews from them and it's
a win-win because you could both get the
reviews and you get
uh exactly uh exactly the the the
technology vendor does not have any veto
rights they don't get to edit the review
so it's very possible and it happens it
happens sometimes those reviewers are
actually critical of the products that
you use
um but that's part of the game because
if they're all five star reviews it's
not credible at all right
you all know that right you go to you
got a page on amazon it happens all the
time right
and i see all these reviews and they're
all paused and it's like okay
something's going on here
and then and then you see a couple of
the one stars that and they're they're
in length and then you then you feel
something is fishy
yeah exactly but then but if i see a lot
of like say four star reviews
where someone said this was really good
but it didn't work for me in that
that's that's the most credible review
right and so that's where we
we aim for is to get those credible
reviews
that provide both you know this is
what's great about it but also
it's the room for improvement i love it
i think i remember
i remember somebody back in in middle
school or high school they told me that
it's it's
always much better to get a 97 on a test
than 100
because 100 means that the test was easy
you just you just aced it if it's a 97
it means you worked really really hard
and it was a really hard test and you
still got a good score
so i think it's exactly the same thing
you want to get those fours and those
five you don't want to just get all
fives because that
that diminishes the value of those
reviews russell but i want to transition
also to a little bit about work from
home because we're almost out of time
but i want to hear a little bit about
your you know your leadership style and
you know covet is unfolding
you're still running the team what do
you do how do you as a leader come
and approach this crisis yeah um
so there have been a few guiding
principles
i think the first is compassion
um you know kovid has affect
many people in the world um
from a health perspective from an
employment perspective
and um we're you know we're fortunate
here in the company we've grown
since covid we did not have any layoffs
we did not have any pay cuts we've grown
we're hiring we're continuing to hire
but uh still it starts with compassion
um again we're fortunate we've
you know none of our employees have had
any serious
to my knowledge uh health issues as a
result but
but it's always knowing that whether you
any
people might have a family member a
friend what what have you who's affected
by it and so it all starts with
compassionate
um and to articulate that so so that's
number one number two is communication
so
i really had to ramp up my communication
with the team
after we you know because we we shifted
from being in the office to working
working home from home we're now we're
now back in the office
uh many of us but but for a period of
time obviously we were all working
remotely from home
and so there it's really about over
communicating so
you know i would do some things that i
hadn't done previously i was
sending what's up messages to to the
entire team
we were doing some special types of
um videos to keep the team entertained
and obviously we have more
i would have more frequent uh meetings
uh with my
uh cabinet my uh management team
uh with the entire team so we just
increased communication flow that was
that was
that was also really important um not to
underestimate
again the challenges of working from
home right on one hand
for some people it's um some people
really like it but
um there it it can be very tiring it can
be very tiring to work from home
i really just want to be there and
support the staff support the employees
so those are the things that we did and
you know we did some fun things
had some fun along the way as well a
couple of couple of staff had to go into
quarantine
so we had a rule that anyone goes to
quarantine gets a pizza
sent to their home to feed their family
for the night uh so we sent out a bunch
of pizzas and then
and then people would then take pictures
of the pizzas and share with their team
so
sort of became this fun fun company
activity so to come up with those kind
of creative things that we did
russell that is so so cool thank you
again for being so generous with your
time this is
this is so interesting and i i learned a
lot over these past 20 minutes
before we leave i'd love to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
yeah uh i'd say always be learning
that that is something that um i i've
always had a thirst for learning
uh it's one of the values of our culture
credo here in the company always be
learning we're all
here in the company there's a mandate to
always be learning um
the funny thing is when you get to be my
age you what you do is you learn that
the more you learn
the more you don't know so i i i'm
uh in this now cycle where the more i
keep learning the more i realize i don't
know
so much and there's so much to learn um
so it can be sometimes uh quite a
challenge
but uh that's something that i think is
really a driver for who i am
very very cool russell about thank you
very very much
uh best of luck with both with the
covert but also with
with it central station it sounds it
sounds really incredible what you guys
are doing and i love the
the the different intrinsic motivations
and and the thought processes behind how
to get
this to be to create actual value and
not just artificial value
on the surface of it and it sounds like
this idea behind growing a community
that actually cares and actually wants
to help and wants to be shown and seen
while creating value for them too is an
incredible accomplishment
so russell thank you very much thank you
michael it was fun
you